- It's time for another
segment of "Designed by Drew",
where we get to create
a brand new space for incredible people.
And today's Designed by Drew viewer,
I think she's here for some design advice,
and has no idea that we
actually have a brand new room
waiting for her behind those doors.
(sharp giggles)
Okay, first, let's meet the mom
whose strength and positivity
are truly inspiring, take a look.
(gentle upbeat music)
- My name's Kerin Mackechnie,
I live in Scarborough, Maine,
I have two little boys, Jack and Drew,
who are six and nine years old.
I met Ian, we were both 22 years old,
and within about an hour or
so, I knew he was the one,
and I leaned over and
whispered in my friend's ear,
"This is the guy I'm gonna marry."
The happiest that Ian and I
have ever been was that summer
when we first moved into
our house in Scarborough,
it's our dream home,
and we put in a lot of love
into pretty much every single room
except for our master bedroom.
Our thought was, "That's the only room
"that nobody goes in, but us,
"so, let's put all our
time and effort and money
"into the rest of the house."
We knew we needed to buy
some new decorative items
and kind of spruce the
pace up, make it our own,
and so, I went to Christmas tree shop
on the tight budget I was on.
And so, I came home with this
sailboat painting and I said,
"Ian, someday, my bedroom
will match this painting,
"and this will work on the
walls in there and it will go,"
and he was like, "Okay, all
right, someday, not now,
"but I agree, someday."
One of the happiest days of our lives
was the day that Drew was born,
but it was the day after
that in the hospital
that Ian's mom looked at him and said,
"Your coloring looks
off, it looks different,
"and I think you should
go get it checked out,"
and he was diagnosed with leiomyosarcoma.
His reaction was always,
"Okay, so what do I do next?"
No chemo scared him, no surgery,
he just wanted to know what was next,
he wanted to beat it,
and he wanted to beat it
because he had two little boys at home
and he had me, and he had
this whole life ahead of us.
I remember saying goodbye to Ian
when I had to bring him
to the hospice house,
and I knew he was never gonna
come back to this house,
and I remember saying to him,
"We painted every wall,
"we've done everything
to this house together,
"you will always be in
this house with us."
(soft ambient music)
Ian is a part of our
life every single day,
everything's daddy this, daddy that,
we have photo montage videos of him
that my kids will say, "Friday
night, instead of a movie,
"can we watch daddy's video?"
And we have a lot of fun,
there's no way I can waste this life
that Jack and Drew and I have together
on not being happy and enjoying
everything we get to see
and everything we get to experience,
it's hard, but they can't
not do that for him.
(crowd applauding)
- Okay.
(Kerin giggles)
Why, and how do you know
that positivity really
has an answer for you
or could be an answer for anyone?
- I don't think there's
really any other option.
Life's short, things happen
that you have no idea,
you don't know what
tomorrow's gonna bring,
so, I live every day knowing that
a lot of bad can happen,
whether it's cancer, whether it's COVID,
life can change on a whirlwind,
and staying positive
and trying to be the best
person you can be and be happy,
why not? Why would you not wanna do that?
- I couldn't agree more.
When a choice doesn't seem easy that day,
what do you turn to,
to go and get back to that positivity?
- Yeah, for me, honestly,
it's that Ian doesn't even
have that choice anymore,
and I have these two little boys
who were four and six when
their dad passed away,
and their dad is, and always will be,
and should be their hero.
And I live every day and
there's things I get to see,
and experience, and do,
and laugh, and have fun,
and Ian would give anything
to do those things with us
and watching someone go through cancer
to watch someone who is
saying, "Okay, what's next?
"Okay, I'll do that chemo.
"Sure. I'll try that surgery."
How can I not now live and be like,
"Of course, I'm gonna have fun,"
he made these horrible choices
just because he wanted
to be able to have fun
and continue to have fun someday.
I'm healthy, I'm able to have
that fun with Jack and Drew,
and show them that life
can be really hard,
and it's just about looking
at what you can change,
what you can be in control of,
and finding the positives,
being happy and being kind.
- I know in honoring your home,
you've taken care of the kids' spaces,
and you've fixed up everything
and done your little things,
and you've left this bedroom
sort of as a last step,
and I would imagine that
changing the bedroom
probably has a lot of emotional
ties to it as well now,
is there any conflict
or does it seem like,
"Okay, it's time?"
What is going on in you?
What's your inner dialogue?
- So, 2020 was like kind
of a turning point for me,
going into 2020,
and at the beginning of the year,
his clothes were still everywhere,
my closet was half my
clothes, half his clothes.
And I finally, I think
it was after COVID hit
where it was like we're
all now in our homes
and kind of analyzing and
thinking about our lives
even in a deeper level,
and it was sort of like,
"I think I'm ready to put these away,"
they're in the basement in bins,
they're not going anywhere,
but they're not in my bedroom,
so, that was my first big step.
And then next has been,
"Okay, I gotta get rid of the stripes."
(both chuckle softly)
My yeah...
I've now at the point where I think Ian...
I know that Ian wants me to be happy,
and I think that any positive thing
that happens to me and the kids,
I do believe that he can
see me, I think he sees us.
I choose to believe that,
I have to believe that,
that he sees all the things
that Jack and Drew do,
and that I do,
and I think he'd be really happy and ready
that I'm now mentally in
a place where I can say,
"Okay, I can make this what
we always wanted it to be."
It goes along with the whole 2020 for me,
moving forward and making these strides
that I really wasn't able to do.
He passed away in 2018,
I wasn't able to do that
until I all of a sudden
was, and that's okay.
- I think it's just incredibly
healthy and I'd be honored
to discuss it with you, I live for design.
- I've heard that and I
think that sounds amazing.
(Kerin laughs)
I'll take any advice I can get.
- Perfect. And I know
where your heart is at,
so, we're gonna do this
respectfully and thoughtfully.
- Perfect.
(gentle upbeat music)